we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk you know what you love it we're
back is it the new year it's a few days
before the night all right happy new
year we're back logging here because uh
some people are going on vacations
what you're going upstate and i'm
working i just want to blame you
you're going to resort i'm going to
milwaukee
improv
you're doing a vacation before though
well you're not here on christmas in new
york is like kind of i'm a jew and i'm
still like this is special i don't know
i do
you a christmas guy joe huge my favorite
time of year yeah i'm sorry we should
introduce you before
our good friend one of my favorites give
it up for joe derosa guys the underrated
never got his due
the cranky curmudgeon i was gonna say
wet blanket you name it i think i've
quoted one of your bits on here saying
one it's one of my favorite jokes of all
time where you said how you're adopted
and people ask do you ever try to find a
meet your real parents and you go uh no
i took the hint actually
that's one of the best jokes
thanks one of the only tight jokes i've
ever written
i'm usually up there rambling about
something
thank you what do we got today uh beer
jew uh today we have pretty much a
classic the boulevardier oh
very nice
similar to negroni just with whiskey
but legend has that it came before the
negroni oh in paris oh okay and this
american writer in paris is this uh so
it's sweet vermouth
uh whiskey and campari absolutely okay
smells good for the for the people at
home this is a big moment because joe
rarely drinks
cursed me out two straight years for
leaving your birthday party
i was leaving your birthday party and it
was like 3 a.m and you were like you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
it's like a fun
i might need to look into this because i
was just over at bar stool for doing kfc
and um
he was like
you're big drinker that was like he led
with that he's like
like not like accusatory or combative he
just was like you're a big drinker right
and like we and all of my questions when
i did ask the internet were like if you
had to give up one of these which would
it be and what one of them was always
booze
and uh and then that's my intro here
i don't know yeah
i like to i like to have a little sauce
sam we do too we got a show about it so
you're you're in good kind of good
company i mean i get concerned when you
start saying things like ah we're just
gonna have one don't worry about it i
was like what kind of drunk show is this
we might be drunk sometimes we're drunk
sometimes yeah all right fair enough
we're pros we got shows tonight you got
another pod to do but we'll make it work
i got another pod to do then i can go
right home you're loading up today yeah
there's three pods today three pods we
appreciate you squeezing please i'm not
squeezing i'm happy i'm delighted to be
here i thought you guys were going to be
mad at me that i had to cancel last time
no no no no
everyone's busy this is really good by
the way very good this is so good what's
your name i'm dan dan it's great
great work dan thank you we love him man
yeah he's a pro real mixologist let's go
back to let's go back to
what you said earlier about never got
his due or all that
no no no it's not bad okay
no i was in the bathroom peeing and i
was thinking about the two of you and i
was like
these are two guys i remember when they
first came around yeah and i believe you
both have
lightning bolted past me wow
you guys are doing millions of views on
youtube you're you're kicking ass i
remember meeting you you were when i was
like a brand new comic you were one of
the nicest people to me
consistently thank you so much you
really were you're a genuinely good dude
i always liked you a lot i c are you i
used to come and do that show that you
went harrison that's right yes
yeah well you were
you were always so humble and i i assume
it's the adoption
i'll tell you i'll tell you we're
getting humble get you being humble gets
you that's the way it's not the waiting
not the way you gotta battle around with
your [ __ ] waving around you know you
look at who's really out of my way and
they're mostly terrible people yeah
they're mostly people who are not
they're never like the oh shucks you
know right i don't know but then you got
david tell who thinks he's the biggest
hack and he's funnier than all of them
yeah exactly i'm literally at the point
now where i'm when somebody asks me
what what is success to you it's like
you know being content and loving the
people around i'm at that point of
failure
the podcast is doing great though no the
podcast i'm i'm joking around the
podcast is doing great both of my
podcasts are doing really well which i'm
very very lucky about and uh
and uh eclipsed with salvo condo so it's
taste buds is the name of the pod taste
buds is the one with sal yeah yeah dude
the the clips never fail to make me
laugh they're so good oh thanks
such how has no one come up with that as
a it's so good so relatable then you sit
there and you think about it well i
actually like oreos and you get into it
now you want to listen a whole lot yeah
it's funny how vehement people get in
the comments the fans like people really
really have some real fire and in these
times of like left first right men
versus women all that [ __ ] the politics
it's just nice to veg out on some uh
cookie debates that's the same thing
kevin just said who's kevin kevin clancy
barcelona
literally the same exact thing he just
said he said i love the show because i
feel like it's it's a cure for the
internet what the internet is now
because everybody's bitching about
politics and all this stuff you guys are
arguing about han solo and luke
skywalker that's all we want yeah right
the recent one was uh cherry you did
cherry coke and sal did root beer yeah
and sam roberts took uh
dr pepper
i'm with you i think i go cherry coke in
that one what root beer all day really
see we're doing it right now
it's a hit root beer ranked lowest in
the poll what yeah i grew up with rupert
has got to float there you go
you could do a float with cherry coke i
know sal really tried to lean on that
float argument nobody gives a [ __ ] blow
it is out
it's not that good either it melts
immediately it just starts to taste like
creamy it's a fun idea yeah it's it's
like a s'more it's like that's a fun
idea but it never really actually
crumbles a lot of work yeah like eating
ass on paper it seems great and then
there you go your night's covered in
breakfast
tastes good i wanted to join in
now there's a taste buds ass or balls uh
i guess we've never licked balls i'm an
ass man myself as long as it's clean
it's your favorite i i don't mind it ash
yeah yeah yeah i like it same it's got
to be real
it's
particular kind of freaky yeah it's not
like pizza you know you gotta really you
don't want a deep dish
i get it you want a thin crust
yeah certain foods like i can do like uh
i can do cheap like italian but pizza
but i can't like chinese at this point
has got to be good for me if i'm on the
road and there's chinese food i'm like
i'm not i'm not trying i'm not trying
missouri chinese right it's the worst
thing for you it's just sugar and sauce
and rice and all that [ __ ] see here in
the city though but i love it
and i live right near chinatown so i i i
go in there all the time and get
you know the real deal [ __ ] like
where as real does get the duck and all
that stuff which i love but i gotta say
in the city
i love nothing more than like just the
joints like i love the little takeouts
where you get like the classic spare
ribs the big fat egg rolls oh yeah you
know that's kind of harder to find in
some of the better spots
and you know in new york like i'm saying
if you go into chinatown to like some of
the like more traditional spot that's
american chinese is i guess is what i'm
getting that's what you like it's like
the text message i just i do love it do
you ever go to woo hop we would just
talk about that i know it's amazing
there's a place on this block that's
insane yeah so wohoop is like the
ultimate version of american chinese
like it's it's all those classics but
they do it better than anybody yeah
what's your go-to order there
i get i'm i'm big on spare ribs and egg
rolls i'm almost always spare ribs and
egg rolls for me like that's that's i
always go that route and then i usually
get like a general sals chicken yeah
yeah that's a tough one to i mean dude
that's like my christmas day orders
what's that's big yeah yeah general sews
and sesame the sesame's right sesame
seeds is that it and then general sal's
is uh spicy
ah those black peppers oh those are good
those are a [ __ ] yeah they come
out of nowhere yeah but that's the
difference but you know the chinese
moved here and they were making their
traditional food and nobody bought it
and they added a bunch of sugar and
sauce and then this went through the
roof because we're fat
it's like that old richard jenny joke
how the french had the croissant and
americans did the chris sandwich
yes we put chocolate and cheese in it
yeah we go hard i mean the double down
the [ __ ] what's the sadness bowl oh
the kfc thing
how do you feel on fast food love it
yeah it's my achilles heel it's it's
it's it's
[Laughter]
but we went to this is the saddest story
we got drunk one night this is 20 years
ago we got hammered one night i can't
remember who we were with and we ended
up at penn station at the kfc
i remember that night you remember that
i think i might was that with you i
might have might have been
with you there was a good
god damn it there was a uh
i missed the good old days there was a
good old drinking click yeah it was it
was you
mark sam me
soder soder
nate barcelona bar oh
god but it was like that was like the
core five
i remember nate holy [ __ ] this is talk
about times change right
nate
could only get spots
at the [ __ ] world yeah the thing next
to broadway yeah the world so nate would
always be there like i got a
[ __ ] 11 o'clock yeah
unbelievable unpaid like they were
making money i mean they were charging
cover i mean that's this is like assad
guys
now i know it's like wild right he was
hilarious then it's just like people
don't recognize it you know i mean yeah
yeah it's why but the people at home
broadway comedy club was uh
it's still around but it was it was a
bit of a scam room they go hey we got
dave chappelle here oh they're gonna
kill one person said we have tina fey
here i'm like she doesn't do stand up
this is who you're pitching we got
richard pryor here
on the wall there's a mural it's
horrible it's still around but they
would bark you in fake alcohol
whoa oh
because he was like here well oh should
we not be saying this well we'll beep
the name well wait not not fake but it
was like
it was like that syrup or some [ __ ] it
was that corn based stuff that like you
could sell if you didn't have a liquor
license right because it was near a
school so i think yeah it's not
i'm not allowed near that was that
eastville used to do that did did
broadway do that too
the original eastville before they got
their license did that then they got
their license what they did it was like
12 percent you ordered vodka but it had
the alcohol content of wine i think
right because it was that you know 12
whatever but uh i got spat on at that
club yeah that's how grungy that and to
the credit the waitresses they were so
[ __ ] cool that like they bare this
guy i just heard a guy get up uh and i
was like oh [ __ ] this guy's gonna we
were going back and forth he gets up and
i hear him go
and i was like [ __ ] nails me right here
all these sassy hispanic waitresses uh
barricade the stage for me
and i'm just i just watched chris murphy
walking me out whoa yeah he was like
he's waiting for you so i'm gonna walk
you away he's a great guy great guy
first threesome i ever had was the only
time i got spat i got spat on in philly
and then i had a threesome after the
show it was a very different spitting
story yeah these two girls were like
[ __ ] that guy come on let's go drink and
we went out drinking and like we had a
threesome why spit on them and my cousin
yeah remember my cousin goes did you
leave with those two chicks i go yeah
and he goes
i gotta start getting spit on
yeah yeah it's not a bad night but um
but broadway was scott moran you guys
know scott murray yeah i love moran
great guy um he used to have that great
web series that he did called
um comedy
what was it called comedians the comedy
they did a bunch
did one and giannis papa did one about
getting shot yeah and phil hanley did
one on crowd work that's right mine was
at broadway comedy club most of the
footage and the reason scott was
following me that night was because it
was when
my mom had just gotten over breast cance
gotten through breast cancer and i was
doing a lot of material about it so he
goes i want to follow you
and document you talking about this like
tragic thing that your mom went through
and then like now you're doing it on
stage and i was like okay
we got to
we did the first show then we went to
broadway
and during the set on broadway a drunk
nurse started heckling me
and i lost my [ __ ]
and i called her a stupid [ __ ] and then
i lost the crowd yep and then that's
what the show that's what the episode
became about it was about like losing
your [ __ ] on stage and like it was
brutal dude like he came back two weeks
later and had me watch the footage on
camera
and i was mortified and i was like i
shouldn't have done that like i was so
embarrassed i was so embarrassed
but it was this great cathartic
thing like people really liked the
episode because they were like wow you
really let us like kind of see
behind the curtain you know if you if
you never snap on stage you're not doing
bad enough rooms that you're just doing
a room
if you never just like lose it at a
person like michael richards lawyer
[Laughter]
look yeah
i don't mean like that but i mean but
you know if you never snap every once in
a while i mean the amount of disrespect
that we oh i mean last night i did a
show in new york and they're just like
they're just animals they're just the
worst behavior proud and you're like of
course we snap this our life used to be
all that and then you start weeding
those shows out yes but there's a period
where your life is just disrespect show
disrespect show and like of course
you're gonna break yeah and it's not
just from the audiences from the owners
the bookers you get it from everybody
and it's brutal we can't pay you tonight
but we have a panini
well that's what i that's what i always
used to say was that um what people
never understood was
when you um when you would flip at a
heckler
which
i i don't know about you guys i don't do
it much anymore because i'm just kind of
like
i don't know you get it out of your
system eventually and like you start to
learn how to
navigate it a little better i guess or
whatever but like when i would flip at a
heckler
i would always say like you think that
this is like
you and me it's not this is you this is
me and 12 years of this yes right
like you're not
this is a snowball effect
you know so but i i got banned from the
laugh factory in new york for
a year because i flipped out so bad at
an audience and i was so that was so
that was on 42nd and 8th right and then
it became times square art center
horrible and then it became a haunted
house
which was less scary
i remember when it became a haunted
house mike vecchio tournament goes but
then again it always was
there you go yeah and it was before any
of that it was a big it was a big
multi-level multi-room strip club and i
think it was a porn house before all
that yeah yeah so you why'd you get
banned from that club let's hear it
they would have this on saturday nights
the room would just be completely
unpoliced and it was times square so god
knows where this motley crew was coming
together from savages but people just
like literally on their feet screaming
like just
just a completely chaotic room through
the entire show
and i went on one night and that started
happening and i just started going at
all of the i was just like [ __ ] you all
i hope you all [ __ ] get aids and die
in a car accident tonight you're all
pieces of garbage you don't [ __ ]
deserve a show all this stuff
not not not the most clever
that doesn't sound that bad you know and
then you're sitting in the car with a
jerk store called they're running out of
you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they got banned they get
banned for a little
while damn yeah the uh the the booker at
the time
yeah said uh
i don't think you're uh i don't think
you can handle this room and i don't
think you're right for it and i don't
think it's good that you
flip out the way you do and blah blah
blah i guess it was probably the third
time that it happened
that was just your set list
i mean you're just like
you're going on stage waiting for it
you're
watching there's nothing worse when
you're watching the show it's like a f
it's like a firing squad you're waiting
awaiting execution you are watching it
happen to everybody and then you're like
right
i got a hard experience of that club i
was like a really young comic and i
remember i waited all night to do a
check spot and it was me another comic
waiting to do a check spot and he said
we only have room for one would those
you don't know you're literally going on
stage as people pay their bills so it's
the worst time to go on whatever but
i i go on i i say he's like oh we only
have room for one of you uh and the
other guy starts crying he's like all
right you can go on what you didn't want
to deal with the guy crying so he's just
[ __ ] yeah so i remember just waited
like three hours it was like one of
those you're like oh my this is who
wasn't the greatest i don't want to say
okay but we know him yeah yeah but
that's all i wanted to know
and i was like you can't wait for these
mics to turn off brutal
but excited yeah it was yeah i don't
want to why was he crying because he was
i think he was just broken like it's
[ __ ] like that like every night when
you're a young comic and like i don't
even blame him i just [ __ ] up like
that's why you're picking him
uh yeah yeah
oh oh wait he picked him because he
cried yes oh i thought he was saying he
picked you like this kid's crying get
out of here no he i think he didn't want
to deal oh
i misunderstood i thought you got it
i was like oh [ __ ] hey oh that's so did
you watch the guy's set no i was i i no
i no i think he was like he like chewed
up a little bit i was like [ __ ] it but i
know i got out of there i was like
[ __ ] i never went back i was like
that's insane
crazy gary vader
i think it might have been nate
no no no no no it
like believe the reverence
and fear i used to have for these rooms
sounds like same of like worried about
every little thing now i'm just like
hey you want to just come you want to go
on with me who gives a [ __ ] like you
know what i mean like it's like who
cares what you had to do want to do it
you had to go oh sure and that's how
they got you they go you can't handle
this room and you go oh i guess i got to
learn how to [ __ ] on people and crowd
work and all that but that's not what
what comedy should be it should be great
ideas and bits and original but that was
part of it was learning how to babysit
yeah and fear is good i mean when you
see people with not any fear coming up
that's true like well you should be a
little scared this is your life yeah a
healthy balance a healthy balance people
are used to uh fear's a good thing
people are used to uh people think
bombing is like not a big deal that's
why when i see like i'll see instagram
posts from new comics and they're like i
was disrespected by this audience member
and you're like oh yeah you're posting
about that
that was a part of it like that was like
the first 10 years of my
occupation yeah it's it's so funny like
the the shift in of that because it's
like
now it's like yeah i was disrespected by
this argument but it used to be like
watch this stupid [ __ ] get owned yeah
you know like flipped yeah you have some
drunk guy yelling at you and like you
would just walk all over them the place
is going crazy
that was the clip you posted
i mean
bill burr famous the only thing it was
him winning but also the uh also it was
him surviving so i thought crow was a
hostile and burr just really [ __ ] you
but the famous clip is the bill hicks
one where he's just screaming at that
woman and i think a lot so he's just
calling this woman a [ __ ] and you're
just like you watch it now and you're
like it's not his finest moment i don't
know why everyone's and you see comics
who watch that clip if you and they're
like i'm gonna have my moment like that
yes and you're like you don't want to
have that moment no not a thousand
percent did that yeah really i swear to
you a thousand percent
thought that that kind of thing was so
cool and so great
which is why i would flip out the way i
did i was also an angry guy
um do you think you're less angry now
much oh yeah look at him yeah much you
were shaking before yeah yeah heat up i
was ready to go
yeah you are are you a tense guy
probably adoption
it's the last time i'll bring up the
adoption i don't care it's funny all
right intense um
yeah
anxious yeah
you know but usually i'm i i'm able to
navigate it a lot better than it used to
be
yeah you get older you get better at not
taking things personally yeah
you get better at saying i don't want
that part of me to come out
anymore um
you know unless absolutely necessary
which it rarely is
and um it was just a lot of that it also
too has a lot to do with self-worth and
not letting things define
your word i'm kind of on a kick where i
keep talking about this but the second
during the during the lockdown the
second i realized i wasn't valued
because of comedy i was just
a person doing comedy
amongst other things
that was a big moment for me and it was
hard because it was it was it was two to
three months first
of utter anger and fury and depression
that i had moved back to new york to do
comedy and then comedy was gone and at
that point we didn't know what the [ __ ]
was going on yeah you know like it was
like
and it was woe is me and my life sucks
and i moved back for all this
and then when i realized no idiot you
moved back because you like to live in
new york
comedy's part of it but that's only part
of it and then all of a sudden it just
everything changed wow
and that was you because a lot of people
went the other way they went angrier and
the world's against me and [ __ ] you i'll
kill you and you went
hey
life is okay i'm not defined by this
start a podcast blaming the jews you
know
like this isn't the answer right i had a
bunch of road dates lined up
not a bunch but i had i had road dates
lined up for that like
you know sort of coming out of it phase
that we were all in and like when it
went in junior july whatever it was of
that first line yeah when they were
cancelling it like week to week and we
kept thinking this pandemic wasn't going
to go away yeah yeah it was going to go
away i mean i had road dates let up and
i had a tv thing lined up and i
cancelled all of it and pissed some
people off but i was like
i'm sorry guys like i'm not doing this
right now like i don't i don't know it
was weird it was it was weird to go from
a six
in a six month period to go from saying
i have to do every single thing that
gets offered to me and being a complete
slave to it to going
i'm sorry guys not now like yeah and
feeling like very comfortable now we get
it this is our third time asking you to
come on
[Laughter]
sorry i can't do it right now
i know you're right there's a value in
saying no like sometimes we just we are
so trained to be agreeable and just like
dogs for these people you know
team player when the pandemic hit i
didn't realize how much we were on our
foot was on the gas a hundred percent
for years and then when the pandemic i
was like whoa why i didn't realize like
you could you can stop for a second
yeah well that's the thing to go back to
what we were talking about earlier
um with the with when i was saying the
reverence and fear that we had with
these clubs i agree fear is can be a
great motivator
and being scared and anxious is can keep
you on your toes and i think that's good
and it helps you criticize yourself and
whatever but i think more what i was
referring to
was the fact that after this pandemic
well it's i guess it's still happening
but like like after the lockdown i
should say
we were
i won't go back yeah like a lot of i was
just like i can't believe i let so and
so
make me feel
like they were valuable like in some way
in my life like what the [ __ ]
i've spent way too many hours in the
shower going that [ __ ] guy i'll tell
ya and then he's quick comedy since then
i wasted all those hours you know
thinking about him in the shower i
remember till the day i moved to la i
was furious the comic strip wouldn't
book me
furious
furious yeah i got to la i started
writing for tv i started acting on major
tv shows and whatever it was
yeah and uh you're great in that show
thank you very much that's a great show
well you know i'm good by how they bring
me back once every 17 months the uh i'm
kidding
they're great guys
uh gilligan right vince gilligan and
peter did he praise you on the show he's
great he there i think he i'm totally
just joking no i know but he really was
like you were a great actor he's
thankful
do you remember him on louis louis you
killed it thank you that was fun louis
acting
no
peter and vince are really great guys
thomas schnauz is uh one of the eps he's
amazing he's awesome that guy yeah you
know i just know him from twitter but
he's he's just great yeah yeah he's
funny he's he's written on so many he's
written did he write for breaking bad as
well yes he's been he's written for like
everything yeah he's
he's got a great career um and a great
bodywork and jonathan banks and bob
odenkirk everybody they're all awesome
and supportive over there it's so fun
and it's so fun to get to be a part of
something like that where you're not
carrying any of the weight
you know it's fun to get to be like a
like a boba fett character versus a luke
character where it's like you better not
[ __ ] this up right you're like i just
swoop into my scene and i'm gone
jonathan banks is most of your scenes
right
it was in the beginning it was all me
and jonathan banks and then it became
all me and uh odenkirk so
the last
ah well
i can't talk i can't say anything more
but yeah it's a lot of me and odenkirk
but uh exciting but yeah he and he's
great because he has like
you know we really got we got to talking
about stand-up comedy
oh yeah an underrated comic yeah he's a
great mr show with bob and david is like
i mean for so much of of guys like us
that was like our our sketch comedy
bible talk all about that dude really
it's incredible yeah and he would be
like it would be cool because he'd get
excited he'd be like hey man did you do
shows this weekend you know
and i said to him once they go dude
you're such a good comic like why don't
you [ __ ] do stand-up anymore and he's
like i have too much respect for it to
not do wow
that's what's advice for you
i'll keep some yucks going here no he's
uh he's a legend man he's awesome and i
can't like say any of it
for obvious reasons but like
the last time i saw him i was like
what are you working on
like you know off camera obviously and
he was like oh man so and he told me
like a couple hours like [ __ ]
like if you were saying this to 18 year
old me i would be like [ __ ] my pants
of course like
like he's really he's really [ __ ]
cool
he's really funny too yeah i mean that
show that show was huge just just the
fact that they would do whatever it was
it was just even when it was a miss you
were like did they just [ __ ] even the
attempt you respected yeah and it hit so
often i mean and they were ballsy like
if you're watching now you're like jesus
christ i can't believe they said that
they had a whole episode about how
slavery was uh
like they should be thanking us for slim
we brought them here and you're like ah
but at the time you're like this is
funny
wild but they took risk like crazy
that guy jake johnston from the uh mr
show was at the
uh january 6th what did you see that
[ __ ] wait what pull it up dude pull up
the picture jake johnston uh the capital
i'm not making this [ __ ] up that guy's a
great comic actor wait a minute was he
there just to see what was happening i
don't know pull it up i think he got
pelosi's laptop
holy [ __ ] it's hard to recognize him
without the paint but uh no he was the
one in the elk hood or whatever
yeah jay johnston jay johnson jay
johnston he was there
yeah look
i mean it does feel like a mr show
sketch the whole thing
you just see his picture
there he is oh that looks certainly
looks like a handsome guy he's a
handsome guy good job nice eyes
i mean could he
is he into this sort of thing
i mean he's there
i think he's there as a joke
ah he looks pretty bad
well that would be the joke though right
okay
i don't know but here's the thing no one
knew what this was going to turn into
joe i mean i don't think he was there as
a joke
i mean
i heard that it also could just be a guy
that looks like him i don't think so oh
god
there it is
there we go all right we got to move it
a little bit it's getting awkward
dude anyway yeah jonathan it's so cool
about banks and odenkirk is that they
they're kind of like journeymen who
became stars yeah thanks uh banks is the
greatest guy ever um
i uh
last time i saw jonathan i told him
uh and i meant i meant it very much i
told him that i learned more acting i
would learn more about acting from
working in a scene with him than i'd
learned in any class ever took damn and
uh and it was true because the guys
you know they always talk about acts
with your eyes or whatever yeah the guys
just like you look into his eyes and
it's just there's a lot going on you
know yeah and it's in tim he's and that
character is so intimidating
so like you do scenes with him and he's
like so just like he's he's in it man
he's awesome he's [ __ ] awesome and
he's like he's really like
an empowering guy where he'll be like
like i remember the second time i was
ever there he was he was like let's go
run lines we were running lines in his
trailer and he was like
he goes listen to me
you're [ __ ] good so if you need
another take today you [ __ ] ask for
another take don't feel scared all right
like he was like really like wow you
belong here kind of stuff you know like
that helps [ __ ] that's huge goes a
long way jesus you were freaking out on
that sale i know i am i was having a
goddamn [ __ ] i was like trembling the
first day dude i was terrified it's odin
kirk it's better called saul gilligan
it's way out of our league yeah so
that's dude anyway acting class helps
because i've been told you got to take
an acting class and i go ah it takes up
your saturday or whatever and i just
blew it all off
i don't think any of it matters anymore
because i think like
i think um
it's all just sort of
stunt casting thank you beard
thank you buddy nice work
killed it great april
yeah we might be drunk to you as brought
by uh we might be drunk is brought to
you by sheath underwear i love sheath
man love it not only supportive keeps
your balls off your leg it's got two
patches one for your dick one for your
balls but sheath isn't just for men it's
for the lady gays out there she's now
they they wrote this well uh now has
sports bras bikini briefs and boy shorts
the idea for sheath came from its
founder us army soldier robert padden
during his second tour in iraq this
guy's a veteran he's a u.s hero support
this guy support this awesome
veteran-owned company whose founder is a
big comedy fan oh tell him how to do it
you got that right go to sheath
underwear dot com and order with promo
code drunk to get 20 off your first
order and sheets underwear is 100
money-back guarantee that's sheath
underwear.com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls
the uh
so he does he just come in to do this
comes in and makes it and he leaves
how do you how do you what do you pay
this guy to do this well i give him a
couple bucks yeah yeah that's great nice
guys you want to borrow one before his
shift yeah i could make a milkshake for
uh i should ask him is he looking for
work i need we need bartenders at the
bar oh he's got a cake but he's very
good i mean you taste this [ __ ] dude
yeah look great i mean the garnish in a
studio come on this is a little fancy
for joey roses really but you're like
you can do this he can do what we're
doing well you want a little jack we're
like we're like a shop beer
kind of bar you know what i mean you do
and you do sandwich like the sandwiches
are kind of joey roses let's hear about
that you opened a bar you open a
restaurant i mean this is terrifying in
new york speaking of [ __ ] on set
this is a big deal it's a bar with uh
it's a bar with sandwiches it's a
sandwich shopping bar so
we have the you know we were doing the
pop-up
at the stand for all uh most of the
lockdown and everything
uh for takeout only obviously and then
um we you know paul italia my partner
and i started to realize like hey this
people seem to like it it seems to have
some legs so
let's try to open a spot
and we found an affordable spot because
of the rent drop and everything and um
that's it like here we are we're now in
the east village riving 174 rivington
street there you go check it out folks
what's the what are like the go-to
sandwiches what's your favorite right
now we just have the original eight
sandwiches so i like all of them but
like you know people love the fat kid
which is a triple decker peanut butter
jelly with ruffled potato chips on it
um
uh people love
the
the yeasty which is prosciutto salami
olive oil asiago cheese and pep sweet
peppadews
um it's it's a nice little neighborhoody
style menu eight sandwiches eight bucks
a piece there you go
yeah this is were you a sandwich guy i
never have sandwiches oh okay
who's not a sandwich guy i don't love
him what joke but uh yeah our website
this is an older this is a dead page but
if you go to joey rose's nyc nyc that's
how they get you
joey oh this is oh there we go okay
there we go order online we're good the
online is going to save you the takeout
is what keeps everything in business it
bugs me man you know what bugs me though
when you go like i hate going to
starbucks but sometimes you're in a rush
and i go and everyone's ordering by
their phone now that's right so they
take [ __ ] 20 minutes to get an egg
sandwich i'm like i'm here for the egg
sandwich because i'm in a rush exactly
same with the chipotle there's eight
online
a little offensive yeah i'm waiting to
get cancelled for it
that kid that one's the dad on the
bottom right that's like an italian
style that looks amazing
cappy ham and um
but you know it was excuse me it was a
thing i always wanted to do
paul helped me turn it into a reality we
partnered up
and you know as we went along and got
closer to opening this place the more
relevant it felt to us because we were
like
when's the last time the lower east side
has had a place with
affordable great food
and like drinks
yes that you can
afford to buy and you know what i mean
we've got some higher-end stuff but
we've got a lot of really affordable
stuff too it was like the whole idea was
let's give some something back yeah to
the lower east side and the whole place
is old-school feeling and you know
they're loving a picture of it there the
lower east side needs a little of that
because it's getting real she she down
there it is yeah so the whole place is
like kind of old-school social club look
at that sign you can't beat that son oh
that's beautiful man that's like good
fellas yeah you guys got to come down
man i'm going to come i love it let's do
it i can't wait a huge
i'm assuming you guys are working on new
year's eve but we're going to think i'm
taking off
all right well we're doing
we're going hard on new year's eve we're
going to party what by the way can we
get can we do that taste test by the way
now matt can we do that we got something
this joe is
you're basically like a food expert now
i feel like with the podcast so we got
to try this looked weird and we wanted
all to try it so let's let's do it we're
on it very exciting
all right
we argued mac and cheese with joe list
oh what do you think because he loves
mac and cheese doesn't he well he eats
like a special needs eight-year-old man
it's only pizza hot dog burger he can
crazy vegetable craziest sentence i've
ever heard in my life when regarding
food joe list said to me in a text i ate
chicken parmesan almost once a day
wow
let's do it i was like dude that is
insane insane that's insane it's him and
al capone maybe you know who else yeah
this is it right what do you got here
i've heard of this i can't is it regular
dairy ice cream it's mac and cheese ice
cream
i have a dairy thing yeah really one
minute i might be able to take like the
tiny
spit it out like uh like tobacco god
this stuff looks so disgusting i've
heard of it i've seen it looking cheese
ice cream
how could it possibly be good oh we're
passing this thing around like a
stripper in vegas hang tight here we go
i can't tell if i like it it's kind of
not awful it's better than i thought it
would be kraft mac and cheese by the way
so they went real trash
it's not horrible
whoa that's choosy
it is
that's not bad
ah two bites and i'm out yeah well i
mean cetera it's four it's just like it
it's almost better because you're not
gonna go through a whole carton of ice
cream point that's pretty good
you can't do it let me get one more for
the road i'll take one more too i liked
it great nails
[Music]
you gotta swallow it spit it in the cup
in the ice with the ice
oh yeah that's not bad not bad
i mean it does just like it
oh man that's good
better than the uh
the croissant witch or what is it called
the uh
that cookie i kind of like that oh my
god worst thing i've ever tasted come on
you eat us that's normal
i'm surprised that's not bad not bad
they did a good job it's better than the
breast milk ice cream i'll tell you that
whew everybody's going to get kooky with
the flavors man lewin is good dude no i
go there once a week they're good they
do good work by my house
have you had uh
you've had what's-her-faces right
mary's yeah who's the lady
aunt jemima yeah
mrs butterworth janet's what the hell
are they called jenny's jenny's yeah
oh
pull up jenny's i don't know what
jenny's is mark it will change your life
jenny craig it's good no it's
j-e-n-i right
yeah uh-oh what's this
i'm a big ice cream cup is that is that
all of your like go-to dessert type
thing or no
what's that ice cream if you're doing it
now cause i i developed a dairy sort of
slight dairy intolerance with certain
things so i can't really eat ice cream
the way i usually was this some shark
tank nonsense
dude they're little shark joke they got
a double chocolate like midnight black
it's called like blackout midnight
dude is so
[ __ ] good it's like great really they
have an everything bagel ice cream wow
i'm listening yeah people really love it
everything big dude that everything
seasoning is a game changer
i bought a little can of that [ __ ]
amazing jenny sent me and sal
cases free cases of ice cream because
they heard us debating the everything
bagel oh
so they sent
who took which side with everything
bagels that was everything i was
cinnamon raisin
i got everything all day yeah yeah yeah
now i think cinnamon raisin's king why
king it's it got no versatility here it
is blackout hold on that looks blackout
chocolate
wow now what is a pint cost is it 48
it's like 12 bucks oh my god 12 bucks
pricey it's going up now a smoothie is
25 now that's pricey but i'm telling you
dude
you're gonna taste where that extra
money went really yeah yeah it's organic
it's whole milk it's oat milk it's just
stupid it's like
it's unreal dude okay
all right jenny i'll give it a shot
the cow was massaged while he was milked
yeah yeah right is there a store in the
city they've got
or is it all online yeah no they've got
something somewhere but that you can buy
this in supermarkets oh okay that's all
i need
i might go get some of that dairy free
ben and jerry's later tonight yeah which
one what's wrong with that maybe the
chubby hubby or the
the uh cherry garcia even cherry garcia
is a [ __ ] classic for a reason dude
yeah cherry ice cream i mean we need
more of that it's just tough though dude
because you just like you want to eat
the whole goddamn pineapple dude it's
over half of your day's calories you
guys reading sapiens no which i know is
like savings is like the secret for men
but sapiens has a great piece about how
we when we eat ice cream we go back to
our monkey like ancestry where when you
found something sweet back in the day
you just ate the [ __ ] out of it because
there was nothing sweet you know there
was no ice cream there was no candy you
found a strawberry so now we open a pint
we want to eat the whole thing cause
we're like we might never see it again
it's in our wiring really yeah yeah
jesus you can't win
sugar is just [ __ ] addictive it is i
mean more than cocaine they say
yeah yeah i mean it got they got a
couple comics coke and sugar
you got robin williams you got sugar
i've seen sugar get more comics than
that
yeah
you know ron williams didn't die from
coke you know what i mean like
yeah like i've seen more comics die from
sure you know there's plenty of guys out
there where you go how did he die and
they were like dude his car was riddled
with fast food bags yeah
he just died on the road i mean patrice
is crazy diabetes right it happens
the uh coke's at least hard to find
sugar's right there you know you can't
buy coke at a rite aid
you think you couldn't
but you know
[Laughter]
i guess the guy outside are writing coke
is like uh republicans you think nobody
is one until you start doing it and then
you're like oh jesus
everyone's in these guys are everywhere
i've never done coke in my life dude
maybe either i have it it feels great
[Laughter]
but the come down joe the come down is
the worst thing of all time but that
also has to do a lot to do with if
you're not doing good coke ah if you do
clean coke there's not a bad come down
day if but mostly kids if you're
listening yeah yeah just get the good
stuff no a coke come down there's
nothing
nothing worse chocolate midnight cocaine
but i get like i gotta tell you i get to
come down blues now from a night of
drinking too now i got that 10 years ago
it's a nightmare that's why i cooled
down the booze just because the next day
i i get like
god damn oh same we went to death
thoughts come in we went to the jets
eagles game on sunday and we we
big tailgate it was a blast oh wow who'd
you go with you go with jay and all
those guys i i asked jay jay couldn't go
but it was me i went with paul and chris
italia
and adele from the stand oh yeah and we
went out and this guy tommy from wyoming
whiskey was like sponsoring the whole
thing was all this free barbecue full
open bar oh boy full truck of beer and
whatever we had a [ __ ] blast got
shit-faced
and then we all went to the book to joey
roses after and that's day [ __ ] faced
yeah and we continued into the night
sure but like i still was i mean i was
asleep by 11 30. all right but i woke up
the next day yesterday was my day off
and i was just like oh my god
like you just you feel terrible right i
wasn't hungover i was just sad all day
right but it also it
it's that but also like even if i get a
good night's sleep it's not that quality
sleep like the booze just [ __ ] your
head up [ __ ] you up big time you've
been off for a while or not off but like
off not off but like hungover now
well no because the last night but the
last time i saw you you were it was at
the um
patrice benefit was that the last no
that can't be the last time i saw you no
but no we did the patrice benefit and uh
that was that two years ago yeah jesus
christ yeah well the panda i remember
seeing you there and being like let's
drink and you were like i'm kind of
stuck yeah well i'm not going as hard as
i did because i physically just i can't
do the road like that like i can't do
more i'm down the road every week i
can't do morning flights just feeling
like it's incredible that you guys are
out there every week i i admire it i
couldn't do it i think
you do learn to love it honestly like
you get to a point where you're like it
becomes routine enough that you're like
yeah i mean i value those long sets man
you know i love the long sets i love it
it's the
i hate the airport and flying worse than
anything
i get into a i get into a rage
in the airport like i don't get into
anywhere else in my life it's so
unnecessary it's so regimented group one
group two yeah terminal b it's like ah
yeah but that's because you do different
airlines yeah maybe this is you fly
every week you gotta stick with one
airline no way if i if i flew every week
i would but mark doesn't do that
anything i'm like you get you miss out
on all the status [ __ ] maybe you're
right but still you got to still do
security
but do you have clear i do and you're a
pre-check i don't i have to use a
pre-chair i got to do preaching are you
kids
meeting at the
there's a place in midtown that does it
the same place i had to go get
fingerprinted to get approved for my
liquor license it also does pre tsa
pre-check really yeah they do a lot of
stuff in that office to help you get
get cool stuff into your life yeah
i have friends
who are like i don't want the government
to have my [ __ ] i'm like they already
have it i don't care about that just
[ __ ] and also uh
no it just makes your life so much
easier then you stick with one airline
you get the lounge access it's it's
great yeah that's pretty good what's in
the lounge i've never been in oh lounges
they've got a they've got a bar they've
got coffee they've got food they've got
an open bar or just i don't think it's
open bar it used to be they changed it
up a little bit so the lounge is good i
always thought the lounge was just a
private room that was like that was like
the gate except private it makes you not
hate the airport you go in there like ah
you got room there's no animals in here
all right i can't i mean i get like i'm
not i'm not exaggerating i get like dad
in a christmas story mad at the airport
like where i'll literally be walking
around cursing out loud to myself right
like i get i i [ __ ] hate it so much
it's a nightmare and we can go there
more than anyone yeah
so anyway but back to what we were
saying
you can't do the road like that anymore
is what you were saying yeah i mean
there's been many flights where you get
up and you're shaking you're hurting so
bad you just want to kill yourself and
you're in the middle seat and it's too
much with the hang of it i mean we told
this during the pop but there was we did
a gig with schumer once in florida and i
remember puking in the bathroom at the
airport and mark's just handing a ginger
ale over the thing for me
yeah i mean that's where we're at i mean
it's a young man's game you kind of
there were too many like 7 a.m nights
i'm like i can't write new jokes if i
feel like this all the time i can't tour
if i feel like this all the time so it's
like i don't want to give up booze but
you got to kind of make a people like
i'm not going to go that hard because i
can't i'm i'm going i'm going to start i
start going out again in january 2022.
in fact helium buffalo uh january 2022
i'll be there uh hasbro heights bananas
nice february uh i think march or april
punchline philly
um i'm i'm basically going to do one
week in a month
through 2022 just to kind of get back
out
polish off the hour whatever
but
youtube special would be a huge thing
that's what i'm gonna do all right let's
do a youtube special put it on the no
press channel with taste buds and oh
i love it yeah but but um well you guys
listen man you guys really
i think
open or helped open
the door to doing that it's like look
what you guys did there they were doing
this before well of course but
i felt like you
you two shane
and joe list were the four that i saw
where i was like okay
this is possible
we don't have to ask permission anymore
like you can do this like it's a waste
of time to ask for permission you know
because
what happens is
they don't just reject you they sit on
it and reject you after like three
months
so you're like that's true so it's like
if they just said no that week i'd be
like all right but they [ __ ] make you
you're like i'm working on [ __ ] the
whole time i'm now i'm now sick of the
material good point so it's like we're
all about turning over let's go let's go
we got a lot of new [ __ ] yeah imagine if
dating was like that you know hey you
want to go out for a drink
maybe
and then you're like i'm getting laid
trust me it's three months i'll get laid
no let's get to it this girl this new
girl she's named hulu she's awesome
no it's a it's it's infuriating so you
just it's
they've lost a lot of power i mean they
really have lost a lot of power because
then you see some of the [ __ ] they do
make and you're like well enjoy that
[ __ ] awful special
enjoy making dog [ __ ] it's a bad combo
is out there right now
so many of the best comics are on
youtube right now yeah it's it's
they are though you're right but the
trick the trick is also i always say um
hey man if they're if they're willing to
give you the money take it don't be
stupid right but realize they're gonna
bury it yeah but don't take but don't
think you need the money you know what i
mean like if they're willing to give it
to you great take the money and get a
nice payday and do your thing
but don't make that the end goal because
the trick is not just saying i'll do it
on youtube the trick is saying the trick
is understanding i don't need these
other people
because i think a lot of guys look at it
like well i could do it on youtube i
guess but you know what if and it's like
stop put the what if out of your [ __ ]
head
do it that way make a mission statement
make a plan and just do it
it doesn't matter there's nothing it's
going to be different but i don't i
don't see anyone blowing up off like an
hbo special anymore no that was coming
that's what i'm saying i mean it's it's
really netflix or youtube at this point
like you know amazon has buried some
like i think eddie pepitone special was
one of the funniest i've ever seen
hilarious and they and they just kind of
didn't promote it properly and you're
like that dude deserves better he's such
a great channel daniels
first one was out independently first
and then amazon started streaming it
so that's a little different but if you
but the second one i don't know do you
see the interface every special looks
exactly the same well the problem is is
that they also made that comedy dynamics
deal yeah it's like who turned me down
for an hour by the way really and then
i'm watching i'm on there and i'm like
what is this yeah like
you're putting like open micros out with
i guess maybe they're shooting it
themselves and then that's what it is
whatever but like
but you know it's just like we don't
need that stuff like i i it's better
this and long term it's better because
you sell it to hbo and you make a payday
but you'll make more money on the road
if you just keep with this youtube [ __ ]
and you keep promoting elsewhere and all
these social media problem is we're
insecure we want the approval we want
the the netflix to tap you and go we
like you and you go oh okay this is
pretty good oh i got 300 grand
right but
it's not just that it's that if you if
you're trying to get on like shows to
promote your special hbo special still
sounds way better than youtube sure
especially if you're trying to get into
some of these old school programs like
you're not going to get booked on
whatever good day morning show yeah if
they're like it's a youtube schedule if
it's hbo special they're like we're
listening which is probably why they
don't tell you the numbers because you
go hey i got 8 million on youtube
but i got 1 million on hbo so
but that's the thing
like what you're talking about the old
programs it's like they don't do
anything yeah you're better off
posting it on your instagram or your
twitter whatever you're promoting
and that's going to get you what you
need it's like who the [ __ ] goes i
watched good morning america today and
learned about this thing
i'll watch some of those shows i've like
cbs sunday morning on the background
sometimes like i've discovered some
people really sure yeah sure oh i'm a
dog act what are we talking who's on
good morning america
um i was on once well i mean i mean like
on hour three i'm not bragging but uh
i was on at the end oh but uh no
what are we who's on there
i mean it's a big show dude that does
good numbers but it's like kelly
clarkson cbs sunday morning is like six
million viewers really yeah dude sure
it's got viewers absolutely but it's
like doing um it's it's like if you did
rogan
once
it doesn't mean anything it's like if
you did the tonight show with carson
once
it doesn't everybody makes it i think
that meant something i think well carson
won steve martin says the opposite in
his book he's like he's like a lot of
guys i remember saying like oh i you
know i did carson once and changed my he
goes i did it 16 times people still know
why whoa
you don't share that story yeah so like
or however many times you but it was a
lot but anyway my point is is like the
chances are
you could go on the biggest platform you
could perform stand up
on new year's eve ball drop on nbc on
the dick clark countdown whatever the
[ __ ] it's called you know some
whatever the most watched program of the
year and
it doesn't matter it's like it's like
it's it's most of the time it's
consistency most of the guys that popped
off of rogan for example are guys that
went on multiple times
in a concentrated point where you see
brook krishna's like work ethic and it's
like he's calling into every show he's
doing ever i mean you're right it's not
just rogan it's everything so right by
the way that [ __ ] ball drop like
that's people that go to that time
square
they're they're escaped mental patients
even this year you know it's gonna be
popping like it's gonna be packed oh
yeah it's what the [ __ ] is wrong with
people why is that a thing no bathroom
they wear diapers it's wild it's so
crazy seven a.m i don't understand who
thinks that's fun but yeah it's people
are not cleveland yeah they like it
but you know like i'd rather be in
cleveland
too actually
yeah i i can't i don't care i used to do
i mean you guys used to do this too
right did you ever do caroline's on new
year's eve oh we did it i don't think i
did do it i think oh really i think i
did it all the time and for whatever
reason i never did new years but i've
done bad ones i've done new york rooms
on new year's no no caroline's was great
it was fun we did it with wolf soda
paid like
stupid amount of money you get a ticket
to go see the ball like you could walk
in and out you didn't have to just stay
there it was great i think it was like
you did like
back and i don't know if it's still this
but back in the day it was like you did
like
two 11 minute sets or whatever yeah like
it's like
500 percent
no it should be it is it was like not
even that how much they're making that's
like nothing
and then they'd take you to the roof and
you'd watch the ball drop safely with a
police escort from the roof i brought a
girl to that it was a game changer yeah
i was in yeah that was a hell of a fun
back in the day oh it was the best that
was a fun hang on i had some fun nights
there dude oh yeah
i'm open for some back in the day i
would open for like they hooked it up
samantha you was she she was awesome she
was great yeah it was like gilbert
gottfried i opened for all kinds of
comics there oh my god kale jb smooth
jeslik i remember uh jim jeffries yes
yeah uh all those all those fun week jim
was like the most fun guy to hang out
with yeah jim was fun
yeah those guys i used to hang out with
jim there i used to hang out with uh
glenn wool there i used to hang out with
um i used to open for patton all the
time there
wow um uh um
kevin pollock dang
i bet he's a cool dude he's the best
really great guy really great yeah yeah
didn't you do his podcast i did yeah
nice guy yeah he just [ __ ] on me for an
hour but it was really yeah he's funny
he's like a ball breaker and yeah he's
fun oh no he's a fun [ __ ] i like
kevin a lot usual suspects i mean that's
like how many comics do you see in those
types of roles that's pretty cool i know
and he would he's one of those guys too
he'll tell you every story yes wow
you'll be like he worked with lemon and
matthau and he's like oh yeah
larry david did
kevin pollock's podcast larry david's
like you're good you're like a great
interviewer and he's like thank you
thank you wow and i'm such an ld fan
that i was like wow he's blowing pollock
it was fun dude that's uh those old
lemon and math movies uh i'm just i
can't believe i'm this late to the
criterion channel but i've been just
cruising through i mean they've got so
many the apartment is such a great movie
it's on yeah so many classic movies yeah
is that a wilder yeah
[ __ ] billy wilder bro i think that
was best picture it's incred jack lemmon
was the man he's the man arguably the
greatest american actor whoa whoa
hey dude is it you're right
brando
listen
that's what i'm saying arguably
he's got range
he's not american meryl streep he's not
not so good of an actor
i didn't know that you didn't no daniel
day's like scottish but he doesn't do
like inter no i think he's yeah scottish
or irish he doesn't do interviews that's
why he's or very few at least well what
about uh hoffman philip seymour
listen these are all great yeah no he
said arguable yeah arguable i'm arguing
jack lemmon uh dude do you ever see the
the glenn garglings with him is so good
i just bought the uh 4k
shot factory version isn't it great on
cyber monday i got a deal on it what a
downer of a movie but still best movie
it's my second favorite movie of all
time what's your first hannah and her
sisters wow good movie we just talked
woody allen well we just talked about
like thanksgiving movies and that's kind
of a thanksgiving movie yes begins and
ends on thanksgiving yeah yeah that's
right yeah that's a great that's so
that's not that's your favorite movie
the most insightful movie i've ever seen
because because of woody allen's
attempted suicide and his newfound ever
it's everybody it's it's everybody like
the inner monologues
of every character that they play
throughout that movie are just like
holy [ __ ] yeah it felt like that there's
a scene the one that rocks me the worst
is uh or the most is uh
there's a scene where diane wiest and
carrie fisher are competing
to hook up with the same sam waterson
sam waterson yeah yeah and uh
and carrie fisher edges
diane wiest out and like it's that
classic thing where you that happens to
you with a friend and you're like yeah
they're always doing their [ __ ] cute
yeah [ __ ] and like you're so you're like
i'm more worthwhile what the [ __ ] you
know
and she's in the back of the cab
and just the way she's going through it
in her head
as they're driving to drop her off and
she's just like
she's always acting so cute but she
doesn't know anything about that and
then she just goes
uh what the hell it wouldn't have worked
out anyway i'll just take an extra
volume tonight and get into bed and
watch you and you're like how many times
you felt like that when you're like oh
[ __ ] it i'm better off like i'll just
i'll have a couple extra drinks i'll
it's just so so relatable oh my god dude
it's still really heartbreaking i love
diane we so much i mean she's amazing
always incredible especially the woody
allen movies but i mean but when i was a
kid by the way i used to play in the
park and she would be there with her
kids like my mom said you would always
be playing diane wiest was always just
like playing with you as a little kid
that's amazing dude she's she's such a
legend and i mean bullets over broadway
she's like yes
and that movie another thing about that
movie is michael kane just like i ch why
did i [ __ ]
what was it worth like that's cheating
that's what cheating is yeah that whole
thing like he's obsessed with the sister
they have the affair then the whole
thing about that everybody resents
hannah because she's never she's always
the one that's like the pillar for
everybody
and everybody's like don't you get tired
of being so perfect all the time like
it's just a earth-shattering heavenly
man yeah it's heavy
and hilarious and hilarious and the
parents the way the parents fight when
they're singing and the mom's like a
drunken flirt the you know
uh it's probably the best woody allen
really i think it is it's in the convo
it's funny yeah and the funniest woody
allen joke when he goes uh when he goes
uh
she goes uh it's not cancer he's julie
what's her face from the simpsons this
is klausner yeah partner or whatever
marge yeah
oh homie and she goes it's not cancer or
she goes what are you worried it's
cancer and he goes don't say that word
and she goes it's not it's or you think
she has a brain tumor yeah
it's not a brain tumor the doctors just
said it's not probably not a brain tumor
he's like they have to say that or else
the weak ones might panic
wow
also not to mention one of the best
movie soundtracks ever i've heard that
song before the bobby short i'm in love
again like beautiful music in them yeah
yeah really beautiful yeah yeah be which
bothered and bewildered elephants gerald
[ __ ] yeah heavy [ __ ] there you go good
stuff i'm with you i love them yeah what
was that mid 80s
yeah it's like 86 or something 85 i mean
it's right in the that's like peak
he was in woody he was in the [ __ ]
zone
it was like crimes and misdemeanors
manhattan not too long
yeah like he's like he's like in the
[ __ ] groove right then oh yeah but um
but yeah criterion i just actually hit
up barnes and noble did the black friday
cyber monday criterion 50 off sale so i
just bought like
like literally i'm not even kidding like
uh i don't know 15 or 20 criterion
blu-rays do you still watch dvds oh i
still collect yeah i collect
that guy yeah i collect video games and
movies really yeah and music what do you
what like what movies did you have to
have for criterion
i got a bunch i got video jerome which
is an amazing james woods um i don't
know uh david cronenberg movie oh phone
number
yeah it's a wild movie
why it's wild
was that one it's one of his really
early ones right it's one of the earlier
earlier croninburg super early
um so i got that i got nightmare alley
which is an old film are we making it
with bradley cooper looks good really
yeah what's guillermo del toro i think
yeah it looks dude it looks [ __ ]
visually insane it looks great it looks
great are you
huge
a
horror
a huge heart what do you go to i don't i
don't know a ton about horror it's not
my go-to genre but if there's a good
like uh dana gould uh told me to watch
the thing and i was like that's an
incredible movie really
so okay so the thing is a masterpiece
yeah dana gold okay so dan i'm friends
with dana but i'm
really good friends with his girlfriend
okay yeah
cat yeah yeah and so
i called kat one day to catch up
and she was with dana
and she put me on speaker and dana's
like hey man how you doing i'm like hey
and i go i have a bone to pick with you
this is one of the only people i could
ever say to and he's like what is it and
i go i was watching eli roth's
um history of heart he's like uh-huh and
i was like well you were on
the creature features episode
or the monster movies episode yeah yeah
he goes okay i remember this yeah and he
goes um
he goes yeah yeah and i go you're
talking about the thing and he goes yeah
i mean i go you called the thing a
monster movie and he's like yeah and i
go i consider it more of a creature
feature and he goes
you know what you're right
[Laughter]
and then cat goes what the hell is the
difference and then he just goes
i don't have time
to re-teach you on all of this
oh my god you can hear the vagina's
drying
conversation
jesus
this is something everybody yeah that's
like a one of a kind it's like who else
could i have had that that's amazing
what what video games do you collect
sega genesis yeah i have about 40 uh 40
systems you feel like a sega guy
i have uh
i just got the new atari jesus i got the
ps5 i got the xbox series x i got the
nintendo switch but then i i collect all
the old systems so i've i have the
master system i have the sega genesis i
have the sega saturn i have the segment
what does master mean does that mean you
can just play any game no the master
system was their thing that compet
competed with nintendo oh i never heard
of it it's called the sega master system
what do you play the most
i play a lot of atari i play a lot of
atari 2600 um
what is on it what games
well there's tons of games but like you
know there's
spiders i mean where are we going here
kong's on there but i don't really [ __ ]
with pong uh spider fighter
is a game i really like frankenstein's
monster is a game i like quite a bit uh
but i like the simplicity of the 2600
like it takes you back
and i still play like the new call dude
you're a simple man you like your jack
daniels you like your sandwiches you
like your atari there's something about
sitting there with a joystick with one
button
that's true with these like archaic
noises coming out of the tv
and just
it's simple man you're right the [ __ ]
aliens like that's it and we're going
back to with apple it's just one button
it's a lot of simplicity yeah you're
playing against yourself atari is golf
like you're playing against that's it
like how good are you great
do you like um like the modern systems
do what what's a really good modern game
i don't know a ton about video the ps5
is insane really i like the xbox series
x i like both uh both of them and i like
the switch too but the ps5 is doing
things with the controller that are just
nuts like like what
does that shake i mean that's old
fashioned they added like
i would assume it's like thousands of
different vibrations into the controller
so every single thing that's happening
in the game it's like a different
vibration it just really puts you into
it and then this audio interface they
have where some of the stuff only comes
out of the controller
whoa and the other stuff comes out of
the tv so i'm playing a game called
death loop right now
and
like yeah
you're it's a first person thing and
it's on ps5 yeah
and there's a woman that you're in
communication with
who's basically like manipulating you
and like taunting you
obviously
you're trying to break this death loop
that you're in
declare yeah
exactly
but like her voice only comes out of the
controller so everything on the screen
is happening and then she's and then it
just feels like it's in your ear it's
weird whoa it's wild
that's another level like mental [ __ ]
yeah holy [ __ ] it's incredible what
they're doing now man yeah i think super
nintendo was a real moment in video that
really it was like donkey kong mario
kart goldeneye that really like that
gold knight was n64
oh [ __ ] sorry n64 was [ __ ] to me that
was like the craziest [ __ ] ever that was
basically
i was the perfect age for that why wait
did we go long here on you it's 3 20
already well that's what booze will do
to you all right we'll get you out of
here we'll get you out of here can we do
a shot before we go
we got to do a patreon too we got to
pace ourselves okay all right fair
enough fair enough but uh you're welcome
to do whatever you like you got jack
daniels the good stuff norman
i'll do a happy all right [ __ ] it i'll
do a happy what the hell oh
it's [ __ ] noon
god damn it all right
this is what happens with this guy this
is why you're out till 4 00 am
just pour a little in here we can take
it in the cups right now get a shot
glass
getting a shot glasses oh god you're an
animal
joe's got one of my favorite jokes uh
you used to say like hey i drink too
much i eat like [ __ ] ladies
stop [ __ ] me
i love that joke because it's such a
good point you're like they still fight
me why would i go to the gym yeah why
would i ever get in shape yeah go live
go live for me please go light we got
two more reps to do here and i got shows
tonight
you're good man i had a great time on
here no we love seeing you dude and as
you said i don't see enough i mean it's
always a bummer i don't see enough but i
really would love you guys to come down
to the bar and i'm going to come hang
out one night i'm going to come
definitely be there that'd be fun
that dad looked amazing thank you thank
you and dude plug whatever whatever else
i mean you got taste buds with salvo
conic at the other podcast yeah so taste
buds with salvocano new episodes every
monday thank you thank you sir new
episodes every monday audio wherever you
get it full video on youtube um on the
no press network channel hell yeah uh
we'll see you in hell my horror review
podcast to do with my friend pat walsh
um back oh i like that guy i met him
before he's the best she's so funny i
really like him so funny um the back
catalog is on um starburns audio and
wherever you get your podcasts new
episodes are on patreon at patreon.com
wsyi
podcast and then finally
joey rose's
open now wednesday through sunday
starting at 12 p.m each day full bar
it looks amazing which is new food is
coming and we have a lot of new york
listeners so guys go support joe can i
can i just bring up one thing before we
do our plugs yeah just about the video
games and this is a peeve with i have
with video games now i like the the uh
the hang of the video games you play
with your friends it's like four persons
multiplayer ps ps has like done away
with this you have to play people online
i i had to buy doing the pandemic when i
was living in la with taylor i had to we
bought an xbox to play co-op halo
because we're like this is so [ __ ]
fun yeah but like most systems you got
to set up your email address you're like
this is such a [ __ ] i just want to log
on and play yeah you can still you can
still do that there's a lot of
like with any new device now they're
going to get your info out of you right
uh but
but you can still do the couch co-op
stuff with with the newer systems but
but again this is why i go back to like
i love colecovision and i love atari and
i love in television because it's like
you pull out the system
you pull out a stack of games like this
high
and you just [ __ ] put games yes and
it's just like dude it's just we're just
going back and forth we're playing space
invaders we're playing [ __ ] astro
smash yeah i do kind of miss blowing in
the ah
right yeah yeah totally there's
something about it the old stuff is nice
like i i got this old beamer and i it's
1973 and i drove it around last night
for fun and i got out of it and i closed
the door and i went to a restaurant and
i came back i noticed the door wasn't
clicked all the way you know you gotta
close it and bump it sometimes it wasn't
clicked all the way and if that was
another car a new car there would be a
light on like hey your door's not closed
and that'll run down the battery now
your battery's done right this thing has
nothing to do with the battery it's just
metal on metal right and there's
something nice about that there is
there is i had a 2002 jaguar before i
left la wow jeez
where'd that come what are you my
grandpa dude
here's the thing it was i bought it
excuse me i already did my
i bought it for 1500 cash wow
it ran like a champ
and it was like
people saw it and they were like look at
this [ __ ] car and they're like
yeah man there was like something to all
that you know like pull up an old you
you're i love you know what i love about
joe he's like a real old-timey he's an
old soul also you really are an old soul
yes i feel like you guys are too though
yeah i mean do we play jazz on here
we're talking about criterion movies i
mean we [ __ ] we relate to this very
much yeah we like bills
jaguar maroon maroon or burgundy excuse
me oh damn
we say speaking of speaking of uh
remember the midnight in paris
everything the woody allen
where it's like literally you think
every other era
oh that's [ __ ] beautiful dude that's
what i had with a tan leather interior
it was fifteen hundred dollars how did
you get to that show did it run those
cars don't hold their value because the
older they first of all they it's all
european parts yeah it's a pain in the
ass if you want to get something fixed
and then the older they get the harder
it is to get the parts so most people
don't want to deal with it they're like
give me the new one or don't give me
anything i don't give a [ __ ] right they
don't hold value you can get an old
would you say you have an old beamer 73
beamer how much does that cost
well they're they're hot now so they
went up but i mean
don't say if you don't want to say it
was more than 10 grand okay but not much
more okay well then that's my point like
you're talking about a classic car
vintage whatever right you're spending
more to for parties
let's say you spent 12 grand you would
never get a car that looks like that
that's my point dude there are buildings
that charge a hundred grand a year for
parking in new york insane 100 [ __ ]
ground worse yeah you're right that was
actually worth three grand when i bought
it the guy that was selling it was like
dude i just need to get rid of it man i
like my wife's telling me i gotta get
rid of the car like it's we get laid in
it
blown i did jerked oh yeah how about uh
they [ __ ] around in that car
dude what uh
what website did you find it on
literally guys selling it on the street
what there was i was parked on the
street in l.a i drove by it and i or i
walked by because i didn't have a car at
the time and i was like holy [ __ ] and i
called the guy immediately and he's like
yeah man i could meet you there right
now if you want and he came down and as
i was looking at it three different
people that passed were like
dude is this for sale oh i was like and
then i was like dude just give it to me
just give it to you yeah
it's like yeah like fifteen hundred yeah
you paid him cash went right to the bank
got 1500 out in cash and gave it to him
hell yeah that was it love it just drive
it at home it's been so fun oh dude it
was awesome it was awesome i love a
transaction like that yeah and then i
took it to a steak dinner that i i met
keith and artie fuqua
at prime in l.a and i when i was leaving
artie saw the valet bring my car around
and he goes oh [ __ ] ah who the [ __ ]
broke my granddad's car
i remember after you know artie was in
the tracy morgan crash for those who
don't know and i remember after yeah i
got a lot of money i remember i was on
the steps of the comedy seller right we
hadn't seen him since it and we're all
kind of worried i was on the steps of
michael che and i said man i hope he
didn't spend his money on something
stupid the second i say that he rolls
around in a giant escalator
in a perfect perfect suit i've never
seen him not in a suit since the crash
now keith always says
ari's pee-wee herman suits bugged me
[ __ ] i love keith dude yeah all right i
gotta go down dude
dude i love you guys we love you thanks
for coming check out joe everyone mark
plug some dates man oh and make sure to
email us that we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com rex peeves jokes drinks
whatever you want yeah for the patreon
we love you guys on the patreon uh and
you know follow joe derosa definitely
support his uh restaurant thanks boy
roses thanks
and check out his dates he's gonna be on
the road in
i'm in milwaukee improv kansas city
syracuse
sacramento punchline uh la jolla comedy
store all kinds of good days parker
comedy san diego underrated oh great
town and that's like the nice part of
san diego i got toronto
uh richmond magooby's and timonium
maryland i got hartford funny bone i got
uh
sacramento
columbus ohio beacon theater new york
city one night baby may 7th make sure to
get tickets to that
that's a biggie get tickets uh a few
other dates coming but uh oh i got uh
orlando west palm all that [ __ ] so come
come support hell yeah
thanks guys all right boys comedy
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you